tu es en train d'aller chez quelqu'un
qui vous a fait un truc horrible a dit
ni vous vers la montée oui moi ça m'est
arrivé une fois c'était un espèce de riz
ça s'appelle le riz mafate je crois est
en fait il y avait des morceaux de
viande et comme je n'ai pris 1 où il y
avait un os de dans la dame très
gentiment
elle a ramassé avec ses mains parce que
ça se mange avec la main elle a ramassé
elle à mâcher un peu et elle m'a dit
tiens là il n'y a pas de y'a pas non
elle vous larbi c'est qu'il est la
personne la plus importante chez qui
vous avez été dîner ou que vous avez
reçue chez vous la personne la plus
importante qu'un tous à la durée que
vous avez dit ah ouais là il faut bien
sûr ou bien la personne chez qui vous
avez été dîner la fusion du cg vous chez
vous abonner j'en ai marre non mais
franchement géraldine maillet mois sans
doute françois hollande
ah bah oui si c'est lui il est venu chez
moi non forme sur ouais ouais ouais
quand même avoir un ancien président
quand il était président encore ou pas
quand il était président il est
président elles sont réglées c'est
ouvrait une grosse pression pour le menu
j'avais super peur de tout raté
d'ailleurs on a tout raté
ah ouais quand même c'est cool quand
même
bah oui mais c'est bien bon vivant bah
bien sûr mathieu qui calcule tout qui
pèse tout et tout mais j'aime les bons
vivants à table mahb a très bien joué ou
bernard montiel technique alors moi j'ai
reçu au pyla de nombreux hommes
politiques et des gens du cinéma mais
notamment nicolas sarkozy on avait fait
un gros couscous non il n'y avait qu'un
seul endroit où il devait pas laisser
dans la cuisine et il a foutu le pied
dans la loi il y avait les la semoule la
voyez quoi mai puis la seconde affaire
oui par terre oui oui mais oui est ce
vous le savez qu'en tant il y avait 30
personnes à dîner dont nicolas et il y
avait il a foutu le pied dans la zone a
bis av ait jeté dans le plat j'ai foutu
les pieds dans la semoule
enfin adobe ou alors je n'aime pas en
parler mais alors chez lui
alain delon non à wade et on n'était que
4e
et je vous jure que c'est vrai j'ai peur
je me mentais 1 mais il m'a dit je vous
jure que c'est vrai et m'a dit vous êtes
très beau je sais de quoi je parle et ça
va vite un dîner de cons non
non je voulais rebondir par rapport à
mathieu la question enfin tout à l'heure
tu étais en train de dire que tu avais
pris quelqu'un pour te faire à manger
mais c'était via les réseaux sociaux qui
a trouvé cette personne nous c'est une
agence
non mais c'est quoi cette question par
la personne non je parle là que la
personne était très content de venir
chez moi est de rester 2,2 et 2,6 la
payer en nature
c'est ça la vraie question qui savent
écouter je suis petit et question clé
une personne qui était d'abord je les
payais mais je crois étant donné son
regard je pense que si je l'avais payé
uniquement en sourire et russell fille
cette personne aurait été heureuse
chez moi triki bonne idée chez moi et
bertrand delanoë
non ça va s'en fout ouais c'est pas que
j'aime bien de revoir tout le primaire
de paris ça va tu as eu quoi j'ai fait
ma mère j'aime bien bertrand de doué
mais ça va c'est pas non plus ou faux
bertrand delanoë il était avec nous en
tunisie on l'a vu le matin mais c'est en
train de manger c'est vrai patron de la
noë des tarifs pour tous les temps
tunisie en train de manger des makrouts
voilà la piscine l'amitié de nous voir
et gratter les météorologues beaucoup en
plus il nous a dit en plus de bertrand
delanoë un jour j'ai eu un dîner au donc
arrêté sur peary mairie de paris a
arrêté sa malle maire de paris samedi la
journée en venant au niveau des rebonds
donné
oui sauf chez les très jeunes mais c'est
jacques chirac était venu dîner chez mes
parents
ah ouais qu'il était très ami avec mon
oncle fort et donc ils avaient ramené un
copain il avait même pas prévenu en fait
mes parents j'attire à tirana il était
quoi les phonak
je pense qu'ils devaient être mère
allait pas maire de paris sg les maires
de paris ils vont manger chez tout le
monde
les mères de famille on a rien à [ __ ]
c'est vrai je ne sera pas refaire des
travaux dont la ville et faire des
comptoirs de nous
delanoë à chirac ouais mais alors mais
après c'est devenu après bien sûr anne
hidalgo sera un jalon de charisme c'est
pourquoi mon ami bertrand
elle est de série vraiment il va nous
dire alors raymond là j'ai hâte de
savoir
gg le routier sur jon cornish là moi je
rends je vais pas à manger chez des
personnes connues la première personne
de connu où j'allais manger c'est le
jour où vous m'avez appelé parce que
vous allez acheter une table de ping
pong
si vous étiez coincé avenue des ternes
avec une table de ping pong 250 kg à
faire rentrer dans une voiture et je
suis avec mon camion l'a déposée chez
vous et j'étais tout tout impressionné
tout intimidé c'est en 2009 ou 2010 je
pense
et vous madame en développement qu'elle
rentrait pas dans la maison la table de
ping pong on était trois des arrêtés
pour un grand d immenses cette table et
je me souviens les enfants étaient très
petit et vous avez proposé avec votre
ami de rester manger et j'ai été
tellement intimidées de dire des
conneries de dire de la merde en fait
j'ai dit non je ferais je suis attendu
quelque part et c'est la première fois
que j'étais invité à tant de gens dit
maintenant mais c'est sa vie c'était ça
c'est la première fois que je pouvais
manger avec quelqu'un d'important pour
quelqu'un d'important 2009 sortait des
bêtisiers de france 3 on devait après
avec ses deux grandes stars 2 me en 2010
ils faisaient une halte aux missiles
visait la nouvelle star il faisait déjà
part ces trucs là il faisait déjà la
matinale de virgin radio
il faisait nuit déjà il avait déjà
prévenu déjà faire t elle avec jalabert
sicot voilà ce qu'à travers kelly non
non moi comme j'ai dit alors j'ai juste
ma mère par contre un jour on m'a fait
manger quelque chose à mon insu c'était
l'année dernière à noël on m'avait dit
on m'avait dit ben voilà c'est à viande
non qu'on m'a mis mon assiette
ma mère alibaba zighout et oullins donc
j'ai voûte elle me dit c'est bon je dis
bah oui c'est bon elle me regarde en
rigolant elle me dit bat enfin manger de
l'autruche et bien mais c'est minaj
chalet je suis parti on a fait manger de
l'autruche à mon insu wilde tron on
mange pas à west ham a rigolé à madiba
ses notes russe selon lui a fait manger
de l'autruche à son insu merde mais
méfions boîte à notre âge de manière non
mes larmes certes ces drames de sa vie